our response I've often heard is there
is a difference between someone who's
had three sexual partners and someone
who's had 300 sexual partners you know
it's absolutely fine I think if for you
so
share with a
certain so maybe your number is lower
and maybe the people that you want to
have sex with have similar values to you
it just so happens then both of your
numbers are low but it's actually the
values that you're holding and the
beliefs that you're holding that are the
things that make you compatible rather
than like the fact that you've both only
slept with three people you could also
have somebody who like has lived a whole
life had a lot of casual sex and then
like come out of that and been like I've
now discovered that this is what I want
and actually I want the next time that I
sleep with someone for it to be like
somebody that I'm in a loving
relationship with so maybe they would
actually still be compatible with that
person but their numbers way higher